[Musique]
m
en liquide et aquitaine jean cocteau à
sanofi galets gala d'adieu ni un bêta la
halle au texas et le faire je venais par
des génériques
le fan le grand fan voir un maniaque
celui qui ne se consacre en fait aux
tacots c'est surtout pour désigner celui
qui ne se consacrer qu'à sa passion
quand sébastien jarry à 25 ans regarde
la télé c'est pour s'évader avec une de
ses 200 cassette d'animés japonais
entendez par là des dessins animés rien
amis
[Musique]
le bookeen pas du tout
maintenant
oui ça y est ça
c'est moi une quel genre d'animer je
regarde de plus en général ce sont
c'est en général cette série là parce
que quand même très réaliste et puis bah
les dessins animés qui m'ont bercé mon
enfance j'aime bien aussi les mangas
romantique
je suis un coeur sensible quand même les
japonais font des dessins animés pour
tous styles pour tout est pour toutes
catégories d'âge
il ya des dessins animés pour enfants et
des dessins animés pour adolescents il
ya des dessins animés pour adultes il ya
des décennies bourges gala d'adieu qu'en
gt gt enfin j'ai fait un rêve qui se
répétait de temps à autre aujourd'hui je
ne le fais plus se référer
quand j'étais petit ça revenait très
souvent je rêvé que j'étais comme une
sorte de petit sauvage devant une grande
montagne ont connu blanc et c'est
tellement fou j j'en ai déduit que
j'étais j'avais été un enfant japonais
dans une vie antérieure tae cette zone à
oman et y adopte avec popol
[Musique]